microsoft's 13 and a half inch surface
laptop 4 has a few key internal changes
making this a much better value than
before and it has a couple standout
features
that might make you want to buy it
instead of a different windows laptop
but depending on your use case there are
also two downsides that you have to know
about
if you're going to buy one before i get
into everything you need to know i want
to thank microsoft and microcenter for
sending us the intel version for this
review
micro center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive variety of
electronics
from gaming vr computer parts like
processors graphics
and everything else you need to build a
pc they also have a huge variety of
desktops
laptops and all the accessories that you
need not only that but also highly
trained staff and low prices
check out our local micro center today
to get your hands on a variety of
products before purchasing
or use the link down below to view the
surface laptop 4
at microcenter.com they're also giving
away free bluetooth headphones to my
viewers with no purchase necessary
just grab a coupon from the link below
and head to a local micro center
we've got two versions of the surface
laptop for our blue one is an intel
version and the black has an amd
processor
and i'll let you know which one you
should buy on the outside they look
identical to the previous versions
either all aluminum or an alcantara top
which is soft touch which does feel less
premium but very comfy
and i would actually prefer this one if
you are careful to keep it clean
last year i praised the overall look
since it was modern and premium
but lots of companies have stepped up
their latest laptops with better
materials and slimmer bezels
so these thicker bezels do look a bit
dated in 2021.
in those bezels we have a 720p webcam
with windows hello login which i love
and the mics are on the front so quality
for video conferencing is also quite
good
here's how the webcam looks and how the
microphones sound
it's not class leading but it is very
good for the money
especially if you're buying the base
model i have to say that my second
favorite thing about the surface laptop
4 is a sharp display with a 3x2
aspect ratio most windows laptops come
with a 16x9 screen
and some have now moved to by 10 but 3x2
allows you to have
much more vertical space which is really
helpful while being productive on a 13
inch screen
with that i love that microsoft is using
a custom resolution of 2256 by 1504
which equals to 201 pixels per inch
where most competitors use 1080p based
screens
which are noticeably less detailed or 4k
screens which really drain battery life
this resolution is a perfect middle
ground brightness is still the same 400
nits which used to be great
but now the best laptops use 500 nit
displays so it's now
average and with that the display is
still glossy
so you have a harder time seeing it
outdoors or in bright rooms because of
reflections
so you will need to max out the
brightness most of the time the keyboard
is also a strong point of this laptop
and it's very easy to quickly and
accurately type on
the trackpad is also really good being a
large and very responsive
trackpad and although it is using a
diving board design it has a nice even
feel
another thing that really impressed us
was the speaker quality
now if you're trying to find speaker
grilles on the surface laptop 4
you will not find them because the
speakers are actually beneath the
keyboard
and to our surprise they actually sound
great they're not only louder and have
better sound quality than most windows
laptops but they're actually slightly
louder than the 13-inch macbook pro
the sound quality isn't quite as good
but it's still very close
i have to say that they're one of the
best speakers we've heard on a 13-inch
windows laptop and more than enough
for streaming shows and movies the other
thing i have to praise this laptop for
is the software since it's coming
directly from microsoft it's using
a very clean version of windows without
all the extra software from the
manufacturers or
bloatware like games antivirus and other
trials that you have to deal with what
really annoys me
is the extra software that you have to
find and tweak in order to get the full
performance of your machine
on top of what's already built into
windows so here you don't have to deal
with any of that
and before i get into my favorite change
with the surface laptop 4
let's talk about the biggest downside in
my opinion and that is
the ports we're still getting a
full-size usb port for those legacy
connections which is always nice to have
and a usb type-c port for more modern
devices and cables
along with the standard headphone jack
and microsoft's magnetic surface
connection port
that will instantly disconnect if you
tug on the cable although the usb type-c
port can be used for charging this is
the port that is used to charge the
laptop with the included
65 watt charger which also includes an
additional standard usb
port which can be used as long as the
charger is plugged into the wall
last year we complained that the usb-c
port doesn't support thunderbolt 3
which means it doesn't get those ultra
fast speeds and you also can't connect
an external pci or graphics card unit to
the laptop to boost the graphics but we
didn't make it a huge deal because not
everybody needs that
and laptops back then were just starting
to add these ports well now
most if not all laptops in this category
not only switch to thunderbolt 4
but they have two of these really
capable and future proof ports
so it's now really weird to see that a
new 2021 laptop
doesn't even have one thunderbolt 4 port
microsoft says it's because thunderbolt
isn't as secure but
every other company is using it and
while i can understand what they're
saying
what i can understand is that the only
ports that they include
seem to only run at five gigabits per
second
meaning transferring an ssd file maxes
out around 350 megabytes per second
real world speed now a few websites have
listed it at full 10 gigabit per second
but most sites don't mention the speed
just like microsoft doesn't
which is weird because for their
proprietary dock
they actually list 10 gigabit per second
for each port
every fast device that i attached only
connected at the slower speed
so to me it seems that these ports are
in fact
the slowest usb 3 which makes no sense
if you're not going to include
thunderbolt
why not just put in the fastest usb like
my other amd laptop
i personally don't think there's a good
excuse for all the ports running
at that faster speed if you have the
expensive dock but half speed if you
only have the laptop
or you can't bring that 1.2 pound dock
with you
that does need to be plugged into the
wall and now let's talk about my
favorite part
of the new laptop and that is actually
the base
model a few years ago it came with 128
gigabytes of ssd and 4 gigabytes of ram
which was really hard to recommend
and the following year the ram bumped up
to 8 gigs but stayed at 128 gigs of ssd
but this year you get 8 gigs with 256
gigs of storage which is usable for most
people
and it comes with an amd six core
processor that actually
beats out the more expensive intel i5
option
that has a 300 higher base price tag
while it gets better battery life
as well of course we have higher end
options like an i7 which has better
graphics and slightly faster cpu than i5
but those cost a lot more and then you
need to start looking at
other laptops like the xps 9310 that
competes better at the higher price tag
but personally if i was buying a surface
laptop 4
that bass spec is now a killer value for
somebody that needs a windows ultrabook
and doesn't need thunderbolt you get a
minimalistic design with a clean windows
install
a nice and sharp touchscreen above
average speakers
webcam mic keyboard and trackpad really
good battery life
and great performance for a bass spec
now of course i do have to mention the
macbook air which comes in at the same
exact price point
but is better in each one of those
categories but if you need
windows or you just don't like macos and
you're looking to spend around a
thousand dollars
this machine would be my choice if you
want to see us compare the surface
laptop 4 to the m1 macbook air you guys
can click that video right over there
and if you enjoyed this review click
that circle above to subscribe and help
us reach
1 million subscribers before the end of
this year we would greatly
appreciate it this has been max and i'll
see you in the next video